now you might want to wake up early
because the super bowl is all about
those party snacks
so if you haven't finished planning
maybe you have to wake up early on
sunday morning alex because
it's not too late yeah you know who's
ready though already hector mejia with
the assignment of the day
hey hector show us those waffle fries
we've been dying to see them
the assignment of the entire month so
since we're talking about super bowl 55
i'm on my
55th meal of the morning including these
delicious chicken wings and i have
my water here standing by so i don't
know yet how spicy these chicken wings
are gonna be
joining us live this morning we have
mark cooper here at victory burger
but before we talk about these delicious
chicken wings
go bucks or go chiefs for you it's got
to go bucks
out of the way brady number seven
let's let the young kid knock him off
and then we'll talk about a new
goat potential and mark it just so
happens that we have
seven wings right here you were talking
about number seven those are actually
six wings but yeah let's just pretend
it's seven
so tell us you know for all those
families at home you were telling me
when you're making chicken wings it's
all about the crunch
it really is it's all about the texture
the sauce is great
but that's secondary so what i would do
with with any form of a chicken wing
is i would go ahead and cook it
initially at 400 degrees
for a couple minutes to get that sear in
that crunch
and then finish it off at 350 degrees
until 165 degrees fahrenheit
so i can smell the uh the sauce from
here
describe to us exactly what's in that
sauce you guys make everything here
yes sir and it is a sweet chili which
gives you
a a sweet initial note
and it gives you a kick in the back end
you can never go wrong with the wings
no it's awesome it's awesome with the
winch so
i'll go ahead and just show you a little
bit of
oh goodness now we finished that off
now do you like your wings dry or extra
saucy
me i like to mix the sauce oh so do i
it's about getting messy
without it dripping out your arms and
you were just talking about talking
about messi this boom boom sauce here
yes sir
do you describe this as thousand island
dressing
but on steroids yeah i mean if you're
gonna look at the color and you're going
to look at the texture
but then it just gives you a great kick
which is amazing
when dipping in fries or chicken weights
take it away whatever you would like
very very popular sauce here
at victory very popular so what do you
say i give this a try can i take the
entire tray or do i only
do the whole thing all right that's what
i feel later on
so i'm going to give this a try john and
alex let's see so many to choose from
maybe i'll touch
all of them so i can keep the entire
tray but let's just
go for this one and uh let's see i'll
give this a try
hang on i'm gonna put my mask back on
yes hector how can i put my mouse going
with my lips not for the sauce
hector i guess i didn't plan that one
out
[Laughter]
you need a mask assistant so yeah i can
taste both
the sweetness and the tankiness and yeah
i guess we need a mask for
you know a mask that will work
and your mouth is kind of dirty from the
food oh man
you've been talking this up all day long
so darn well better be good it looks
like it's tasty the waffle fries are
good
all good ways to uh get some eats on for
a super bowl sunday
i know the circus is going to be jammed
and you know what
hector has just taught us all life
lessons wrong with wings
exactly and if you don't want to share
just touch everything and then
especially right now no one's going to
share your food so it's all yours
thanks hector we'll have to go ourselves
now it's all yours enjoy